tac
comme vous mes amis mes
souvenirs si vous la voyez
revenir dites-lui que mon cœur
laassé viens de rompre avec le
passé je tire ma
révérence et m'en vais au hasard
par les routes de
France de France et de nav mais ditesli
quand même
simplement que je
l'aime diteslui
voulez-vous bonjour pour moi et voilà
tout j'avais son espérance j'étais s
seul
bonheur hélas les
apparences et le sort son
Tromp un autre a pris ma
place tout passe tout casse tout Lass
des grands mots au pourquoi non diteslui
bonjour pour moi
elle croit que j'ai beaucoup de
chagrin aujourd'hui non mais peut-êre
demain je n'ai plus
d'espérance je remporte mon
cœur par les routes de France de France
ou bien
d'ailleurs mais diteslui quand même
simplement que je
l'aime dites-lui
voulez-vous bonjour pour
moi bonjour pour
nous et voilà
[Musique]
tout